a
[Music]
certain research project
it's our second important industry there
the first one was online so
um
so uh so you know it's obviously any
exciting place
you know to to move forward it would be
really good if you can find ways for you
know all parties you know athenia
industry research data or National Labs
to work together and figure out how to
how to
you know how to do what what they do
best and so so that's the that's our
role in those companies today so
what do we have planned well in terms of
the official agenda is a it's a really
exciting uh
Channel but but I'm hoping that you know
it's time between these all this you
know in our in our tricks
you can talk about you know how how we
can move forward
so uh so I should say that you know the
first session will be actually advised
was their associate director
um yeah so um this is really just a very
very broad overview uh talk
um about some relatively new ideas in
um trying to understand how we can
improve Quantum air correction and fault
tolerance by taking advantage of
physical aspects of noise
um that uh that exists at the at the
physical level noise that exists at the
physical level that has certain
structure to it and how we might be able
to exploit that and this is largely a
totally open area there's there's a
bunch of relatively recent papers
um but I want to try to frame this as
just a few key highlights and really
this is more meant to be an invitation
um for you to consider these questions
and to contribute to this field
um so what is physical noise physical
noise I mean uh we know if you believe
quantum mechanics which surely everyone
in this room does uh it's just described
as a completely positive trace
preserving that
um but this is such a rich uh family of
things real physical noise comes in lots
of specific flavors if you ask
um an experimentalist they're not going
to tell you cptp map they're going to
start talking about other types of
specific noise they're going to mention
uh things that the theorists in this
room uh will recognize defacing or
depolarizing noise
but also things like coherent rotations
crosstalk errors so these are uh but can
I just have for a show of hands because
I was looking at the two programs there
was like the theory part of the program
with people like Mark Sandry and then
there's the experiment part of the
program with people like John Martinez
so these are on pretty wide ends of the
spectrum so I'm just not quite sure
where to pitch this talk so who in here
is an experimentalist
okay and who's a theorist like who
submits to like Fox and stock level okay
yeah okay okay so all right this is kind
of a challenging audience uh so I may
ramble a little bit but um
okay sorry in advance
not me
but also probably the audience
um I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
yeah let me try to elaborate so you know
when I say crosstalk um if you're a
computer scientist just think
correlations in the noise but
um experimentalists you know this can
mean all kinds of uh sources of noise
from like
um some kind of ZZ uh coherent rotation
type error to like DC flux crosstalk in
a superconducting device or something
like this there's also leakage or
Erasure errors that can occur this can
be leakage from a computational Subspace
or into some other environmental degree
of Freedom
um there's time and space correlated
errors more generally and
yeah there is a distinction between this
and crosstalk but I don't want to dive
into that
um there's this really cool paper uh by
Google
um where they studied the impact of
um cosmic rays on one of their
processors I think this is the Sycamore
processor correct me if I'm wrong
um and so you know here the errors are
both spatially and time like light
correlated uh when they are precipitated
by one of these events and so we don't
want these types of Errors to destroy
our Quantum information in our devices
this is a type of noise that we may have
to deal with I mean one way you might
try to deal with this is build your
quantum computer in a salt mine uh you
know many miles Underground
and there's also spam errors or state
preparation and measurement errors and
of course this is not a comprehensive
list because there's an infinite variety
of types of errors this is just a rough
taxonomy that uh experimentalists like
to keep in mind and theorists as well
you said uh cpts
yeah that's right there's also not
microbial noise yeah oh yeah well like
seeking TP on the scale of the Universe
I guess it really only has to be
positive you really consider the
universe but
um so you know the theorists view this
this is a slide pitched at the theorists
okay
um you know this is a very small
um
Quantum computation uh when we think
about what's what we want to be doing we
want to have 10 000 logical qubits
actually but even 10 000 physical qubits
would be great and our circuits are
quite complicated
um this is just a circuit from this
paper by printer at all for extracting
syndrome measurements in a distance
three surface code so a pretty simple
thing as far as things go and in order
for us to understand what the noise
looks like in these devices when we
scale up Beyond just a distance 3
surface code we have to make various
simplifying assumptions and so to study
Quantum fault tolerance
uh both theoretically uh both
mathematically and numerically theorists
often simplify that list of noise
processes down to basically two things
depolarizing noise and state preparation
and measurement errors and that's it
this seems like a really dramatic and
vast simplification and you might worry
that we're not capturing essential
features
um so you might worry that we're kind of
in this situation here on the right that
you know theorists are looking for their
wallet underneath the lamp post because
that's where the light is and to some
extent I think that this is true but you
can also provide guarantees about
General noise theoretical guarantees
against General Noise by appealing to
Theory at the cost of some Precision in
your estimate of the threshold
but there are actually good practical
reasons for doing this as well not just
the lamp post effect so for example
Quantum error correction tends to
decohere errors so you don't see
superpositions of uh the bits that
you've just read out from your syndrome
measurement right those things have
decohered they're in a classical memory
now upon America there are several
papers that have shown Quantum error
correction tends to decohere errors
simulations of quantum error correction
thresholds like I said they're only
really possible when we make these
assumptions so um it's not just that
we're looking for it's just that there
is no other place that we can look
basically at large scales there's also
the fact that no experimental data on
below threshold logical qubits exists
that could otherwise guide our
simulation so we don't have medium scale
uh Quantum devices that are below
threshold where we can just measure
these error rates and use that type of
information as input to other types of
simulations we do have medium scale
quantum computers now
um
but uh all of them are above threshold
uh
to constrict this sense
okay so because real noise is
complicated we would like to find some
abstractions that allow us to capture
relevant physical features of noise and
um
maintain
um
uh and and still be able to understand
in a little bit more detail uh physical
origins of noise that we might exploit
in some way
um and so here I want to advocate for
more General Notions of Pali channels so
what is a Pali Channel a Pali channel is
just any convex combination of Pali
errors
um I guess this
yeah it's just any
um this is the Kraus decomposition of
some Quantum Channel acting on a state
row it's just a convex combination of
poly errors acting on the state route
I'm assuming this is a qubit state but
um we can generalize these types of
channels
um I don't necessarily require that
these P's here are normalized just that
they're positive if they're
sub-normalized then I'm allowing for the
possibility of leakage out of this qubit
space okay so if this is some Effective
qubit Living in a larger Hilbert space
like maybe I've encoded a qubit into an
oscillator or into the lowest three
levels of a transmon qubit
um then I can still look at these
effective poly noise models in the
computational Subspace
so these peas are called the Pali error
rates and I want to consider General
probability distributions over all four
to the N Pali operators I don't
necessarily want to consider completely
general ones because completely General
probabilities over 4 to the N outcomes
is also
um a pretty vast space but we can
parameterize these things by things like
umizing models and we can also study
things where just some of these error
rates are biased in One Direction okay
and I'll give examples of that in a
minute so this is a really large class
but it's much much simpler than the
general class of quantum channels or
Worse non-markovian noise
so I forgot to write it on the last
slide actually but um one very specific
channel that I'm interested is the class
of biased noise channels so um bias
noise channels are just ones where
um I oh I have single qubit noise which
is independent so I'm going to keep the
independence assumption but I'm going to
assume that the Z error rates are much
larger than either the p x error rates
or the py error rates okay like I said
you could imagine more General things
like I could imagine that these that P
of some string X is given by some local
hamiltonian where these X's label these
uh two n bit strings that label the Pali
operators and if this hamiltonian is
local you expect exponential decay of
correlations and you might be able to
still extract useful theoretical
information from these models but
um like I said this talk is more of an
invitation to studying these things so I
don't actually want to dive into this
direction I just want to talk about the
the simplest possible thing where the
only noise correlation is that Z is
dominant relative to X and Y okay just
the baby version I'll also talk about
erasures as well though
um so uh why why should this model help
um so a good intuition for bias noise is
that if I fix the Fidelity of a noise
Channel
um so the Fidelity it turns out
um if I have a single qubit channel uh
is just one minus P where p is the total
error rate between p x p y
and p z
okay
um so this is the Fidelity of a Quantum
noise Channel and if I fix that then the
entropy of this noise channel is much
lower if I fix this sum but I push all
the weight into Z errors right I mean
take this to The Logical extreme uh
maybe don't maybe think if I exchange x
and z Here If I Only Had bit flip errors
and I was promised to this well we would
be in the situation where we only need
to do classical coding and we know how
to do this very efficiently right so the
entropy is just a lot lower and
hopefully we can use
um codes that are tailored to this type
of noise
foreign
yeah I literally mean the entropy of
this uh of the distribution 1 minus p p
x p y p z so if I fix p and I push Mass
over to pz uh the entropy goes down
okay
um so intuitively if I can find codes
and decoders that are more sensitive to
the likely errors in these scenarios I
should be able to much more efficiently
uh protect against the likely errors
um and so here's a diagram from a paper
by Pablo uh Bonita tides at all
um this is a specific code which is
different from the surface code but only
in a very trivial way you just do some
local rotations on every second qubit
um and what you find is that at least
this is for the phenomenological noise
model which for um the experts in the
audience doesn't require simulating
circuit level noise but really only just
assigns State preparation and
measurement errors together with
independent gate errors to um uh to the
noise and um if we take some notion of
noise bias to be the ratio of pz divided
by this sum PX plus py then as I tune
this bias up the threshold dramatically
increases from values over here at
around zero bias
um where the threshold is known to be
about four and a half percent and when
you have bias ratios of about 100 it
rises to about seven percent or even
eight percent biases of 100 are
routinely observed in certain physical
systems like ion traps
um other physical systems as well
oh this is a service called code memory
experiment right so like it's not an
expected this is numerics right but um
there's you know a time history and at
every time you can have a an error
probability of a measurement error or
you can have a biased
um face flip error and with lower
probability a [ __ ] Flip or a y flip
error and then you just decode and once
the success probability for that memory
experiment and it's uh
there's no we haven't concatenated this
into another code yes when you say
standard recorder
means that you're doing xccx code with
or or oh no this would be like a CSS
code with a matching decoder that
doesn't correlate between the accents
and errors actually so that's these are
the results that you get if you treat x
and z independent
okay so then you're gonna do
correlated the color that's yeah it
would improve if you were to do that
this is kind of a Baseline
okay
um to take maximal advantage of these
ideas like so this is just one idea uh
there's several papers about this topic
now
um another idea uh along uh is to
maximize the advantage of this bias so I
the the slide that I showed in the last
um the the results that the graph that I
showed in the last slide
um doesn't include circuit level noise
okay and if you do a c naught gate then
you can map Z errors into X errors with
a c naught gate okay so you might worry
that when I start to include circuit
level noise maybe the advantage of this
bias is going to evaporate or maybe I'm
doing hadamar Gates right so I might I
might convert High rate Z errors into
high rate X errors during the course of
a computation and you are right to worry
about this but there are ideas for how
to deal with this as well
so one idea is from this paper by Shruti
Puri at all where they consider the
notion of bias preserving Gates they
first take a an oscillator and they
encode a qubit into that oscillator into
a specific code this is a curcat code in
this in this paper
um and they show that because of the
physics of how this is encoded the um
the natural noise model that you get in
the system actually is strongly biased
towards dephasing and you can uh you can
um design Gates that Preserve
uh this noise bias a universal set of
gates that preserve this noise bias
now if you uh have this as your basic
set of gates you can concatenate this
into a surface code and try to now
observe a threshold that was done in
this paper by Andrew Dharma Juan and
colleagues also Shruti Puri
um and they showed that if you do this
with an xzx code which we saw in the
previous slide is sensitive to noise
bias and your bottleneck error rate is
the error rate of your controlled knock
gate
um they compared this scheme to what you
get with standard surface code encodings
and they saw it like a factor of two
improvements in the threshold with
respect to this metric
um so this is a factor of two Gain that
you get by first uh taking advantage of
this idea of bias noise and then this
idea of bias preserving Gates
[Music]
um
um good I'm almost done
um there are some other ideas yeah
so is there a sense like
for arbitrary air correction schemes is
there a sense I feel like if you can
engineer the air friction like the
ancillary circuits to preserve bias like
like just engineer the stabilizer
readouts or something in general yeah I
mean like is there a sense in like where
it probably should not
question like I guess uh it's like do
you think error correction just always
would tend to remove bias from delays or
like do you think that I think if you're
naive about it you will
just doing a bunch of random unitaries
um and you have a bare physical noise
source which is the origin of this
asymmetry uh you're gonna scramble that
origin somehow through the course of a
computation so you do have to be quite
careful which is I think one of the
reasons why this uh took a while before
people started really looking into this
there was an early paper by Ella Ferris
and Tesco where they studied
noise assuming bias because
superconducting circuits have biased
noise in them
um and they designed a bunch of fault
tolerant gadgets that were really
gadget for lack of a better word in
order to exactly preserve this bias and
I think it seemed like there was a lot
of overhead and difficulty trying to get
these things to work so I mean it didn't
take off when it shouldn't yeah great
um
so there's another idea uh recently
that's been floating around so there are
a few other dates I'm kind of conflating
something over here this idea of error
transparent dates which is somewhat
related
um but actually the one that I want to
highlight is a little more recent the
idea of Erasure conversion
um Erasure errors we can think of as
being
um
flagged General errors if you have a
general error but you know it's location
uh this turns into an Erasure Channel
and Erasure channels you can correct
twice as many erasures as you can
General errors
um with an error correcting code so it
would be nice if we had a systematic way
to turn General errors into Erasure
errors that didn't cost us anything in
terms of overhead
and again the intuition here is that the
entropy goes down when you do this like
there's just a lot fewer ways to have
these types of Errors so it should be
easier to code for them and to decode
them
so there are now a bunch of them a bunch
of schemes like this that take advantage
of the physical origin of the noise
Erasure conversion in rydberg atoms or
Erasure conversion uh via ion metastable
states where instead of encoding into
certain specific levels using code in
some other level which when it decays to
a third check level it emits a photon
and you can detect this
um so you can label when the errors
happen and then correct them there's
also a dual rail encoded qubit inside
superconducting qubits where uh by
adding some extra qubits and using a
local encoding you can protect against
T1 errors and superconducting devices
this figure is from this paper by
kubitza at all and they show advantages
by considering these Erasure conversion
qubits
so these are some other ideas in this
vein
um I'm almost out of time so I just want
to uh it's like I said this is an
entreaty for you to think about these
ideas so
um
exploiting noise bias for Quantum air
correction is in its infancy I think the
main challenges that we face in this
field are
um their basic physics questions like
how do we engineer noise bias while
maintaining Fidelity my strong intuition
comes exactly from this uh calculation
that I sort of sketched for you that if
you can if you can fix this number P but
you can push some of the some of the
noise into something that is uh has
lower entropy
um and you're an experimentalist then
you should absolutely do that that
should be your number one thing that you
can do uh the theorists on the other
hand need to think about this second
question what codes and decoders do we
need to maximize the utility of this
noise bias so if this noise bias is
towards dephasing or if it's towards
Erasure
um what can we do that's that's
maximizing the hardware efficiency of
this
um and then lastly I mentioned this
paper by ale Ferris and presco
um but there's not a huge amount of work
on protocols that are naturally fault
tolerant or fault tolerant Gadgets in
the more computer science sense that can
integrate some of this physics and some
of the um basic intuition that we get
from studying specific physical systems
how can we integrate this stuff uh in a
natural way so I think this is an
exciting field and it's pretty wide open
there's not a lot of stuff on it right
now so I hope many of the people
watching this talk can contribute thank
you
oh
Big Dog Fitness here so that's another
question so it sounds from what you're
saying uh
you know normally we think of okay so
before control that we want you know a
number of qubits we want to know
Fidelity
so okay
now if you're saying well we could we
could engineer the noise and make sure
that it's biased so is there is there is
there a natural measure that you can put
saying but instead of Institute of
fidelity you know let's look at
something else there's a measure of how
could this uh this implementation is
yeah I mean my uh proposal this has
never been published anywhere but my
idea that should be the idea that I
would like to see if it works is exactly
the entropy let's suppose that we have
uh independent noise
um then we might be able to show
specifically that
um families of codes like service codes
let's say are sensitive only to this
entropy as long as you're using
optimized decoders
um I mean we've sort of shown this in a
series of papers that I wrote with David
Tuckett uh where we looked at this
trade-off with noise bias but I think
you could imagine a much stronger
theoretical result along these lines
um more generally like I said you can
imagine it gives distribution with a
local hamiltonian an exponentially
became correlations but where the
entropy in this distribution is still
extensive or where it's substantially
smaller
um I don't really know what happens uh
it means things like you can definitely
imagine tailoring the code in a decoder
uh to study these types of models I
think these are realistic models for the
types of noise that we see in devices
um I would love it if there were some
summary quantity probably the entropy
um which you could say really
um
controls uh information
Quantum information transmitted through
this channel in a way that's maybe
stronger than a Shannon theoretic type
sense but is practical in the sense that
you know practical decoders and
practical code layouts can achieve some
notion of capacity maybe not necessarily
the actual capacity which
would be hard to calculate but uh
um yeah I I don't know is the short
answer I'm kind of rambling here but I
think there's a lot of scope to answer
this question both from a theoretical
and in America
the side and of course from an external
side as well a quick comment more than a
question there was this paperback too
long and I ripped her something's name
about looking for natural metrics that
decrease under error correction I think
in follow-up work and like slides I
found somewhere they considered looking
at interview the other channels yeah
because I'm like diamond Norman Fidelity
Zone like they vary like what is the
magnitude under here yeah I'm not sure
that there's a metric
that will always decrease I mean if you
promise some features of the noise
as soon as you add some correlations
it's not so clear anymore
you said all experiments are we don't
wrestled but we are at one point or
three so you better have something in
mind
or three meaning like you're uh well the
if you divide it
uh like around the distance
five so we have we're very close to the
pressure
five scaling paper uh shows an advantage
but you don't actually claim to be below
we say we're at the restaurant
sure we're not the buffer so we don't
play I'm being cautious when I say this
Okay I uh I'm very impressed uh by your
work by by work of other groups as well
uh that are approaching the threshold
the threshold as you well know is a
really complicated concept we don't
think we have about threats sure below
whatever
Beyond uh the limit yeah sure I'm being
especially cautious like I said we don't
have these things
with respect uh
no no no no no I'm not trying that I'm
not trying to pick a fight I'm just
trying
to be cautious all right thanks
thank you